yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and I've just seen around 20 minutes of
footage from Avengers infinity war I was
very lucky to attend a fan event and
also caught some funny moments on camera
with the cast who were attending and
right now I'm going to give you a
spoiler free reaction to the incredible
footage I saw if you're new here and a
marvel fan feel free to subscribe as
I've got tons of infinity war and other
MCU videos for you and there'll be lots
more on the way including interviews
with the cast plus I'll be announcing
the winner of my latest infinity war
giveaway later in this video
to give you some context the footage I
saw was from the movies opening act
though it's not exactly the beginning of
the film the clips cover two sequences
one in New York with Tony Stark dr.
strange Wong Bruce Banner and more and
the other in space with the guardians
and Thor fits from some of this footage
have already appeared in the trailers
but obviously we got to see a lot more
of what happens and judging by that it
looks like quite a few of my predictions
based on the trailers are on the right
path as you'd expect from the individual
movies featuring these characters the
tone and look of each of these scenes is
very different which is great as it
seems like the Russo brothers have
managed to retain each character or
group special sense of identity and
brought that nicely into their own mega
packed movie there's a ton of humor in
both the New York and guardians moments
but of course this is just 20 or so
minutes from the early part of a film
that's over a hundred and fifty minutes
long so I think it's pretty safe to say
that as the stakes rise the film will
take on a less comic tone
what's also fantastic about what I've
seen so far is that there's lots of
brilliant interplay between both
characters who spent a good deal of time
together and ones who've never met
before
the action is also pretty special the
music is on point there's some awesome
costume reveals and some cool Easter
eggs all in all the footage was a pretty
delicious appetizer for what looks like
is going to be a totally scrumptious
main course role on the end of April now
which characters are you most excited to
see together on screen in Avengers
infinity war let me know in the comments
and if you got any questions post them
below I can't give out any spoilers now
but I will be doing my usual breakdowns
of the movie once it's out you can also
tweet me
Jan underscore Gilbert or at flick city
I've got more infinity war videos on the
way before the film drops plus some cool
footage of entities with the cast so
make sure you ring the bell to get those
as soon as I upload them the winner from
my infinity war Q&A giveaway is on
screen now if that's you send me a
private message with your details and
I'll get your prize out to you if you
like this video a thumbs up is always
appreciated and you can also check out
more of my Marvel and other videos by
tapping the screen right here thanks for
watching and see you next time you PK
movie lovers